[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to the AI
alignment podcast series at the future
of life Institute today we'll be
speaking with David Pierce and Brian
tamasic David is a co-founder of the
world transhumanist Association
rebranded humanity plus and is a
prominent figure within the
transhumanism movement in general you
might know him from his work on the
hedonistic imperative a book which
explores our moral obligation to work
towards the abolition of suffering in
all sentient life through technological
intervention Brian tamasic writes about
ethics Animal Welfare and far future
scenarios from a suffering focused
perspective on his website reducing
suffering org he has also helped found
the foundational Research Institute
which is a think-tank that explores
crucial considerations for reducing
suffering in the long-term future if you
have been finding this podcast
interesting or useful remember to follow
us on your preferred listening platform
and share the episode on social media
today Brian David and I speak about meta
ethics key concepts and ideas in this
space explore the meta ethics of Brian
and David and how this all relates to
you and is important for AI alignment
this was a super fun and interesting
episode and I hope that you find it
valuable and with that I give you Brian
tamasic and David Pearce thank you so
much for coming on the podcast Thank You
Lucas glad to be here great we can start
off with you David and the new Brian I'm
just giving a little bit about your
background intellectual journey that
you've kind of been on and how that
brought you here today yes my focus has
always been on the problem of suffering
a very ancient problem buddhism
countless other traditions of the impure
occupied by the problem of suffering but
I'm also a transhumanist and what trans
humors and brings to the problem of
suffering is the idea that it's possible
to use technology in particular
biotechnology to phase out suffering not
just in humans throughout the living
world and ideally replace them by
gradients of intelligent well-being
transhumanism is a very broad movement
embracing not just radical nude
enrichment but also super longevity and
super intelligence and this is what
brings me and us here today in that
there is no guarantee that human
preoccupation with the problem of
suffering are going to overlap with
those of posthuman super intelligence
awesome
and so you Brian I've been interested in
utilitarianism since I was 18 and I
discovered the word I immediately looked
it up and was interested to see that the
philosophy mirrored some of the things
that I had been thinking about up to
that point so I became interested in
animal ethics and the far future are you
after that I actually discovered David's
writings of the hedonistic imperative
along with other factors
his writings helped to inspire me to
care more about suffering relative to
the creation of happiness and since then
I've been what you might call suffering
focused which means I think that the
reduction of suffering has more moral
priority than other values and so I've
written about both Animal Ethics
including wild animal suffering as well
as risks of astronomical future
suffering what are called s risks you
had a recent podcast episode with Kai
sitala to talk about s risks I in
general think that from my perspective
one important thing to think about when
steering AI is what sorts of outcomes
could result in large amounts of
suffering and we should try to steer
away from those possible future
scenarios given our focus is on AI
alignment I'd like to just offer a
little bit of context today this episode
will be focusing on ethics the AI
alignment problem is traditionally seen
as something which is prominently
something technical and while a large
large portion of it is technical the end
towards which the technical AI is aimed
or the ethics which is imbued with in it
or embodied within it is still an open
and difficult question broadly just to
have everything defined here we can
understand ethics here just a method of
seeking to understand what we ought to
do and what counts is more or
the end goal of AI safety is to create
beneficial intelligence not undirected
intelligence and what beneficial exactly
entails is still an open question that
largely exists in the domain of ethics
even if all the technical issues
surrounding the creation of an
artificial general intelligence or super
intelligence or solve we will still face
deeply challenging ethical questions
that will have tremendous consequences
for Earth originating intelligent life
and so this is what is meant when it is
said that we must do philosophy or
ethics on a deadline
and so in the spirit of that that's why
we're gonna be focusing this podcast
today on meta ethics and particularly
the metics of David Pearson Brian
tamasic which also happened to be
ethical views which are popular I would
say among people interested in the AI
safety community but I think that Brian
and David have enough disagreements that
this should be pretty interesting
so again just going back to this idea of
ethics I think that given this goal
ethics can be seen as a lens through
which to view safe AI design and it's
also a cognitive architecture to
potentially be instantiated in AI
through machine ethics and that would
potentially make a is ethical reason
errs ethical decision makers or both
ethics can also be developed practiced
and embodied by AI researchers and their
collaborators and can also be seen as a
discipline through which we can guide a
AI research and adjudicated small
impacts in the world there is an ongoing
debate about what the best path forward
is for generating ethical AI whether
it's a project of machine ethics through
bottom-up or top-down approaches or just
a broad project of AI safety and AI
safety engineering where we seek out a
core ability and docility and alignment
and security and machine systems or
probably even some combination of the
two it's unclear what sort of the
outcome of AI will be but what is more
certain though is that AI promises to
produce and make relevant both age-old
and novel moral considerations through
areas such as algorithmic bias and
technological disemployment and
autonomous weapons and privacy big data
systems and even possible phenomenal
states and machines will even see new
ethical issues with what might
potentially one day be super
intelligence and beyond
so given this I think I'd like to just
dive in first with you Brian and then
with you David if you could
just get into sort of what the
foundation is of your moral view and
then afterwards we can dive into the
meta ethics behind it sure so at bottom
the reason that I placed foremost
priority on suffering his emotion
basically the emotional experience of
having suffered myself intensely from
time to time and having empathy when I
see others suffering intensely and so
that experience of either feeling it
yourself or seeing others in extreme
pain carries sort of just a moral
valence to me or kind of a spiritual
sensation you might call it that seems
different from the sensation that I feel
from anything else and so it seems kind
of just obvious at an emotional level
that say torture or being eaten alive by
a predatory animal or things of that
nature have more moral urgency than
anything else and so that's the the
fundamental basis you can also try to
make theoretical arguments to come to
the same conclusion for example people
have tried to advance what's called the
asymmetry which is the intuition that
it's bad to create a new being who will
suffer a lot but it's not wrong to fail
to create a being that will be happy or
at least not nearly as wrong from that
perspective you you might care more
about preventing the creation of
suffering beings than about creating
additional happy beings
you can also advance the idea that maybe
preferences are always kind of a
negative debt that has to be repaid
so maybe when you have a preference
that's sort of a bad thing and then it's
only by fulfilling the preference that
you erase the bad thing so this would be
sort of similar to the way in which
Buddhism says that suffering arises from
craving and the goal is to cease the
cravings which can be done either
through fulfilling the cravings giving
the the organism what the organism wants
or not having the cravings in the first
place so those are some potential
theoretical frameworks from which to
also derive a suffering focused ethical
view but for me personally the emotional
feeling is the most important basis
I would very much like to echo what Ryan
was saying there I mean there is
something about the nature of intense
suffering one can't communicate it to
someone who hasn't suffered
I mean someone who is for example born
with congenital and thus easier
insensitivity to pain but there is
something that is self intimating ly
nasty and dis valuable about suffering
however evolution hasn't engineered us
of course to care impartially about the
suffering of all sentient beings my
suffering and those of my genetic kin
tends to matter far more to me than
anything else and insofar as we aspire
to become transhuman and post humor and
that i think we should be aspiring to
this godlike perspective that takes into
account the suffering of all sentient
beings that the egocentric illusion is
is a genetically adaptive lie how does
this tie in to the question of posthuman
super intelligence then of course
they're very different conceptions of
what posthuman super intelligence is
going to be I've always had in what one
might say a more traditional conception
of super intelligence in which posthuman
super intelligence is going to be our
biological descendants enhanced by AI
but nonetheless still our descendants
however there are what might crudely be
called to other conceptions of posthuman
super intelligence one is this kind of
Kurtz Riley infusion of humans and our
machines such that the difference
between humans and our machines ceases
to be relevant but there's another
conception of super intelligence that
you might say in some ways is the most
radical is this the intelligence
explosion that was first conceived by I
J good but has been developed by
anything you Katsuki Miri and most
recently by Nick Bostrom that conceives
of some kind of runaway explosion
recursively self-improving AI and yes
there being no Garen
that the upshot of this intelligence
explosion is going to be in anyway
congenial to human values as we
understand them but I'm personally a
sceptic about the intelligence explosion
in this sense but yeah it's worth
clarifying what one means by posthuman
super intelligence wonderful and so
right before we dive into the the meta
ethics behind these views and their
potential relationship with AI alignment
and just sort of broadening the
discussion to include ethics and
exploring some of these key terms I just
like to touch on the main branches of
ethics to provide some sort of context
and mapping for us generally ethics is
understood to have three branches those
being meta ethics normative ethics and
applied ethics traditionally applied
ethics is viewed as the application of
normative and meta ethical views to
specific cases and situations to
determine the moral status of said case
or situation in order to decide what
ought to be done an example of that
might be applying one's moral views to
factory farming to determine whether or
not it is okay to factory farm animals
for their meat the next branch moving
sort of upwards and abstraction would be
normative ethics which examines and deep
constructs or constructs the principles
and ethical systems we use for assessing
the moral worth and permissibility of
specific actions and situations this
branch is traditionally viewed as the
formal ethical structures that we apply
to certain situations and people are
familiar with deontological ethics and
consequentialism or utilitarianism or
virtue ethics so these are all normative
ethical systems but what we'll be
discussing today is primarily meta
ethics and meta ethics seeks to
understand morality and ethics itself it
seeks to understand the nature of
ethical statements attitudes motivation
properties and judgments it seeks to
understand whether or not ethics relates
to objective truths about the world and
about people or whether it's just simply
subjective or if all ethical statements
are in fact false seeks to understand
what people mean when they express
ethical judgments or statements so this
gets into things like ethical
uncertainty and justification theories
and substantial theories and semantic
theories of ethics and obviously these
are all the intricacies of the end
towards which a
I maybe aim and given that and given
even sort of the epistemology of meta
ethics and ethics in general that'll
also have major implications for what
AIS might be able to discover about
ethics or what they may not be able to
discover about ethics so again today
we'll just be focusing on meta ethics
and the meta ethics behind David and
Brian's views so I guess just to
structure this a little bit just to
really start to use a formal language of
meta ethics as a little bit of
background again semantic theories and
ethics seek to address the question of
what is the linguistic meaning of moral
terms or judgments so these are
primarily concerned with whether or not
moral statements contain truth values or
arbitrary and subjective there are other
branches within semantic theories but
there are main two branches the first of
that is non cognitivism and non
cognitive ism refers to a group of
theories which hold that their moral
statements are neither true nor false
because they do not express genuine
propositions so usually these forms of
non cognitive sees or things like
emotivism or people think that when
people are expressing moral views or
attitudes like suffering is wrong
they're simply saying an emotion like
boohoo - suffering or I'm expressing the
emotion that I think that suffering
merely bothers me or is bad to me rather
than you expressing some sort of truth
or false claim about the world standing
in contrast and non-cognitive ism is
just cognitivism which refers to a set
of theories which hold that moral
sentences express genuine propositions
so that means that they can have truth
or false values so this is to say that
they're capable of being true or false
turning back to Bryan and David's views
how would you each view your moral
positions as you've expressed thus far
would you hold yourself to a sort of
cognitivist view or a non cognitive to
you I guess we can start with you David
yes I just say it's just built into the
nature of let's say acne that ankeny is
this valuable now you might say that
there is yeah nothing in the equations
of physics and science that says
anything over and above the experience
itself something like redness I mean
what yeah redness is subjective its mind
dependent and yet unless one thinks
minds don't exist in the physical
universe
less redness is an objective feature of
a natural physical world and I would say
that for reasons we simply don't
understand pleasure pain axis discloses
the world's inbuilt metric of value and
this value it's not an open question
whether something like agony is dis
valuable to the victim now of course
someone might say well yes agony is is
dis valuable to you but it's not this
valuable to me but I would say that this
reflects an epistemological limitation
and that insofar as you can access what
it is like to be me and I'm in agony
then you will appreciate why agony is
objectively dis valuable right so the
view here is sort of a cognate of this
view where you think that it is true to
say that there is some sort of intrinsic
property or quality to suffering or joy
that makes it sort of I guess
analytically true that it is valuable or
dis valuable yes well has to be very
careful about using something like
analytically because yeah someone says
that God is talking to me and it is
analytically true that these voices are
the voices of God yeah one needs to be
careful not to smuggle in too much and
it is indeed very mysterious what could
be this kind of hybrid descriptive
evaluative state of finding something
valuable or dis valuable but the
intrinsic nature of the physical is is
very much an open question I think there
are good powerful reasons for thinking
that the reality is exhaustively
described by the equations of physics
but the intrinsic nature of that stuff
the essence of the physical the far in
the equations is controversial physics
itself is silent right and so I guess
here you would describe yourself given
these views as a moral realist or an
Objectivist yes just to jump in before
we get to me couldn't you say that your
view is still based on mind dependence
because at least based on the thing
about if somebody else were hooked up to
you that person would appreciate the
badness
but that's still just dependent on that
other minds judgment or even you have as
somebody who could mind meld with the
whole universe and experience all
suffering at once that would still be
the dependence of that mind that mind is
judging it to be a bad thing so isn't it
so mind dependent ultimately my
dependent but I would say that Minds are
features of the physical world and in
Sofia Russia one can argue for some kind
of dualism
but I'm monistic physicalist at least
that's my working assumption I think
objective moral value usually the
definition is usually that it's not my
interdependent although maybe it just
depends what definition we're using yes
Harriet rather like is that if something
like physical ism is often used as a
stylistic variant of materialism but one
can be a number theorist physicalist and
not an idealist but as I said minds are
objective features of the physical world
I mean I at least tentatively at any
rate take seriously the idea that our
experience discloses the intrinsic
nature of the physical this is obviously
a controversial opinion its association
with someone like Galen Strawson or more
likely phil goff that it stretches back
via grover Maxwell and Russell are
ultimately to shop in her a much more
conventional view of course would be
that the intrinsic nature of the
physical the far in the equations is
none experiential and then at some time
during the late Precambrian something
happened
some not just organizational but
ontological eruption into the fabric of
the world first person their experience
just sort of echo what Brian was saying
the traditional Objectivist or moral
realist view is the the way in which
sort of science is the project of
interrogating third person facts like
what is simply true about the person
regardless of what we think about it in
some ways I think that traditionally the
moral realist view is that if morality
deals with objective facts then these
facts are sort of third-person
objectively true and can be sort of
discovered through the methods and tools
of ethics sort of in the same way that
someone who might be a mathematical
realist would say that one
does not invent certain geometric
objects rather one discovers them
through the application of mathematical
reasoning and logic yes I think it's
very tempting to think of first-person
facts as having some kind of second-rate
ontological status but strallan concern
first-person facts are real and if
someone is in agony or experiencing
redness these are objective facts about
the physical world so Brian would you
just like to jump in with the meta
ethics behind your own view she
discussed earlier sure so on cognitivism
versus non cognitivism I don't have
strong opinions because I think some of
the debate is just about how people use
language which is not a metaphysical
fundamental issue it's just sort of like
however humans happen to use language
but I think the answer to the
cognitivism non-cognitive ism if I had
to say something would be it's messy
probably humans do talk about moral
statements the way they talk about other
statements other factual statements and
we use reasoning and we care about
maintaining logical consistency among
sets of moral statements so we treat
them as regular factual statements in
that regard but there may also be a
sense in which moral statements do
strongly Express certain emotions and I
think probably most people don't really
think about it too much so it's sort of
like people kind of know what they mean
when they use moral statements and they
don't have a strong theory of exactly
how to describe what they mean one
analogy that you could use is I think
moral statements are sort of like swear
words they're used to make people more
feel more strongly about something or
expressed how strongly you feel about
something and people think that they
don't just refer to one's emotions and
even at a subjective level like so if
you say my moral view is that suffering
is bad that feels different than saying
I like ice cream because there's sort of
a deeper more kind of spiritual or more
like fundamental sensation that comes
along with the moral statements that
doesn't come along with the I like
ice-cream statements I think
metaphysically that doesn't reflect
anything fundamental it just means that
we feel differently about moral
statements and thoughts than about non
moral ones subjectively it feels
different yeah so I think most people
just kind of feel that difference and
then exactly how you cash out
that's cognitive or non cognitive is
this kind of a semantic dispute so yeah
my metaphysical position is anti-realism
I think that moral statements are mind
dependent and they reflect ultimately
our our own preferences even if they may
be like very spiritual and like deep
fundamental preferences I think Occam's
razor favours this view because it would
add complexity to the world for there to
be independent truths I'm not even sure
what that would mean based on similar
reasoning I reject mathematical truths
and anything non non physicalist I think
there's moral truths mathematical truths
and so on can all be thought of as sort
of fiction fictional constructions that
we make and we can reason with in these
fictional universes of ethics and
mathematics that we construct using
physical thought processes that's my
basic metaphysical sense just stepping
back to the cognitivism and non
cognitive ISM issue I guess I'm
specifically interested in yourself so
you when you were expressing your own
moral view earlier do you find that it's
simply a mixture of expressing your own
emotions and also trying to express
truth claims or given your anti-realism
do you think that you're simply only
expressing emotions when you're sort of
conveying your moral view I think very
much of myself as an emotivist like it's
very clear to me that what I'm doing
when I do ethics is what the emotivist
says people are doing and yes since I
don't believe in moral truth it would
not make sense for me to be gesturing at
moral truths except maybe in so far as
my low-level brain wiring intuitively
thinks in those terms I just add to this
in that a very it is possible to imagine
say something like spectrum inversion
color inversion some people who like ice
cream and some people who hate ice cream
one thing it isn't possible to do is
imagine a civilization in which an
inverted pleasure pain axis it seems
just bu basic fact about the world that
unbearable agony and despair is
experienced as dis valuable and even
cases that might appear to contradict
this like let's say that masochist in
fact merely confers
they claim because yeah I mean the
masochist enjoys the intensely rewarding
release of endogenous opioids when the
masochist undergoes activities that
might otherwise be humiliating or
painful right I mean so David seems
you're making a claim about there being
perfect convergence in the space of all
possible minds among the pleasure pain
access having the same sort of function
I guess I'm potentially just missing the
gap or pointing out the gap between that
and I guess you're sort of cognitivist
objectivism it seems to be built into
the nature of if let's say agony or
despair itself that it is is fallible
it's not I'm in agony is this valuable
or not it's not an open question where
is anything else however abhorrent your
I might regarded one can still treat it
as an open question and ask is child
abuse or slavery really this valuable
whereas in the case of agony it's just a
built in the nature of the experience
itself I can get behind that and I think
that sometimes when I'm feeling less
nihilistic about morality I am committed
to that view I think just to push back a
little bit here I think in the space of
the space of all possible Minds I think
I can imagine a mind which has a sort of
moral judgment and commitment to the
maximization of suffering within itself
and within the world and it's simply
it's perfect in that sense and it's
perfect in maximizing suffering for
itself in the world and its judgment and
moral epistemology is very brittle such
that it will never change or sort of
deviate from this how would you deal
with something like that is it possible
I mean one can certainly imagine you
know a culture in which displays of
machismo and the ability to cope with
rates suffering a highly valued and
would be conspicuously displayed and
this would be Fitness enhancing but
nonetheless it doesn't really challenge
the Christoffel tree of the pleasure
pain axis as the kind of axis of value
and this value so yeah I would struggle
Turk and see
of some kind of intelligence that values
its own despair or acne from my
perspective I agree with what Lukas is
saying depending on how you define
things so like one definition of
suffering could be that a part of the
definition is desire to avoid it and so
from that perspective you could say it's
not possible for an agent to seek
something that it avoids but I think you
could have systems where there are
different parts in conflict so you could
have a hedonic assessment system that
outputs a signal that this is suffering
but then another system then chooses to
favor the suffering humans even have
something like this when we can override
our own suffering so we might have
hedonic systems that say going out in
the cold is painful but then we have
other systems working you know other
signals that override that avoidance
response and caused us to go out in the
cold anyway for the sake of something
else and you could imagine the wiring
such that wasn't just the enduring pain
for some greater good but the
motivational system was actively seeking
to cause the hedonic system more
experiences of pain it's just that that
would be highly not adaptive so we don't
see that anywhere in nature I would
agree with Francis f yes very much so
okay so given these views which you guys
have expressed and starting to get a
better sense of them another branch of
meta ethics here that my people will
explore how it fits in with your guys's
theories justification theories within
meta ethics and these are attempts at
understanding moral epistemology and
motivation for acting in accordance with
morality so it attempts to answer the
question of how our moral judgments to
be supported or defended and if possible
how does one make moral progress this
again will include moral epistemology
and in terms of AI and value alignment
if one is an anti realist as Brian is or
if one is sort of an Objectivist as
David is then this completely changes
the way and paths forward towards AI
alignment and value alignment if we are
a realist as David is then a
sufficiently robust and correct amoral
epistemology in an AI system could
essentially realize the hedonistic
imperative as David sees it where you
would just have an optimization process
sort of extending out
from planet earth which was just sort of
maximizing for the objectively good
hedonic states and all possible sentient
beings and i guess it's a little unclear
for me how this fits in with david's
theory or how david's theory would be
implemented there is a real problem with
any theory of value that makes offering
either the minimization of suffering or
classical utilitarianism both Buddhism
and negative utilitarianism appear to
have this apocalyptic implication that
if overriding responsibility is to
minimize suffering they know isn't the
cleanest quickest efficient way to
eliminate suffering to sterilize the
planet which is now technically feasible
and that though one can in theory
imagine cosmic rescue missions if there
is sentient elsewhere
there is apparently this not so
disguised apocalyptic implication when
Buddha says allegedly or POC freely I
teach one thing and one thing only
suffering and the relief of suffering or
the end of suffering yeah in his day
there was no way to destroy the world
today there is but much less disgust
indeed I haven't seen it adequately or
perfected not discussed at all in the
scholarly literature is that a disguised
implication of a classical utilitarian
epic that gives this kind of symmetry to
pleasure and pain is that we ought to be
launching something like you to the tro
Neum shock wave where you to the train
'i'm is matter and energy optimized for
pure bliss and the shock wave alludes to
its velocity of propagation and though
humans perhaps are extremely unlikely
even if and when we're in a position to
do so to launch you to the train IAM
shock wave if one imagines a national
artificial superintelligence with the
kind of utility function of classical
utilitarianism why wouldn't that super
intelligence launch you to the tro Neum
shock wave that maximizes the cosmic
abundance of positive value within a
illogical horizon personally you know I
would imagine a future of gradients of
intelligent bliss and I think that is in
fact sociologically highly likely that
post human civilization will have a
Madonna cranes that if very crudely and
schematically as is minus ten to zero to
plus ten I can imagine future
civilization of let's say plus seventy
two plus a hundred or plus 92 plus
hundred but from the perspective of
classical lead to the Terran ISM and
classical utilitarianism is it's
arguably the dominant some kind of
watered-down version at least is
dominant and of secular ethic in
academia and elsewhere that that kind of
civilization is suboptimal it's it's not
moral what apparently has this
obligation to launch this kind of cosmic
orgasm so to speak right so I mean I
think just pushing a little bit back on
the first thing that you said there
about the sort of a very negative
scenario which I think people tend to
see is an implication of a suffering
reducing focused ethic where there can't
be any suffering if there's no sentient
beings thought to me isn't very
plausible because it discounts the
possibility of like future well-being I
take the view that we actually do have a
moral responsibility to create more
happy beings and I've used sort of a
symmetry between pain and suffering I
don't have a particularly suffering
focused ethic where I think that there's
an asymmetry where I think we should
alleviate suffering prior to maximizing
well-being so I guess David maybe you
could just unpack a little bit before we
jump into these justification theories
about whether or not you view there as
being an asymmetry between between
suffering well-being I think there's an
asymmetry there's this fable of Hershel
Le Guin the ones who short story ones
who walk away from Omelas and were
invited to imagine this city of delights
fast city of incredible wonderful
pleasures but the existence of ominous
this city of delights depends on the
torment and abuse of a single child and
the question is would you walk away from
Omelas and what does
looking away from Omelas entail now yeah
personally I am someone who would walk
away from Omelas
but the world does not have an off
switch and off button and I think if one
is whether a Buddhist or a negative
utilitarian or someone who believes in
suffering focused ethics rather than to
consider these theoretical apocalyptic
scenarios it is more fruitful to work
with secular and religious life lovers
to phase out the biology of suffering in
favor of gradients of intelligent
well-being because one of the advantages
of hedonic recalibration ie
ratcheting up hedonic set points is that
it doesn't ask people to give up their
existing values and preferences with
complications I mean if you ask me just
a convenient this is a rather trivial
example imagine you know a hundred
people hundred different football teams
there is simply no way to reconcile
conflicting preferences but what one can
do if one ratchets up everyone sit on it
set point is to improve quality of life
and by focusing on ratcheting up hedonic
set points rather than trying to
reconcile the irreconcilable I think
this is a potential way forward
so yes there are a lot of different
points to comment on I agree with David
that negative utilitarian should not aim
for world destruction for several
reasons one being that it would make
people turn against the cause of
suffering reduction and it's important
to have other people not regard that as
something to be appalled by for example
animal rights terrorists plausibly give
the animal rights moving a pretty bad
name and may set back the cause of
animal rights by doing that and negative
utilitarians would almost certainly not
succeed anyway so the most likely
outcome is that they hurt their own
cause as far as David's suggestion of
improving well-being to reduce
disagreements among competing football
teams I think that would potentially
help like you know giving people greater
wealth and equality in society can
reduce some tensions but I think there
will always be some insatiable appetites
especially from moral theories for
example a classical utilitarian
insatiable appetite for computational
resources you know egoists and other
moral people may have their own
insatiable appetites we see that in the
case of humans trying to acquire wealth
beyond what is necessary for their own
happiness so I think there will always
be those agents who want to acquire as
many resources as possible you know the
power maximizers will tend to acquire
power so I think we still have
additional issues of coordination and
social science being used to kind of
control the thirst for power among
certain segments of society
sorry so and just to get this clear it
sounds like you guys are both sort of
committed to different forms of hedonic
consequentialism but you're bringing up
preferences and other sorts of things is
there a room for sort of like ultimate
metaphysical value of preferences within
your ethics or our ethics simply
epistemic lien functionally useful
indicators of what will often lead to
positive hedonic syn agents within your
guyses ethical theories so personally I
care to some degree about both
preferences and hedonic well-being
currently I care somewhat more about
hedonic well-being just based on so from
my at met ethical standpoint it's
ultimately my choice what I want to care
about and I happen to care a lot about
hedonic suffering when I imagined that
but from a different standpoint you can
argue that ultimately the Golden Rule
for example commits you to caring about
whatever it is another organism cares
about whether that's hedonic well-being
or some arbitrary wish for example a
deathbed wish would be a good example of
a preference that doesn't have hedonic
content to it whether you think it's
important to keep deathbed wishes even
after a person has died ignoring side
effects in terms of later generations
realizing Metra that promises are not
being kept so I think even ignoring
those side effects a deathbed wish does
have some moral importance based on the
idea that if I had a deathbed wish I
would strongly want it to be carried out
if you are acting the way you want
others to treat you then you should care
to some degree about other people's
deathbed wishes but since I'm more
emotionally compelled by extreme hedonic
pain that's what I give the most weight
to what would your view be of sort of
like an AI or machine intelligence which
has a very strong preference whatever
that sort of computational architecture
might look like that's like what like a
bit B flip one way rather than another
so it just keeps flipping the bit back
and forth and then you would have sort
of like a preference utility own iam
shockwave going out in the world it
seems kind of intuitive to me also that
we only care about preferences insofar
as they and I guess this previous
example sort of does this work for me
is that we only care about preferences
insofar as that they have hedonic
effects I'll bite the bullet on the
deathbed wish thing and I think that
ignoring side effects like if
wishes for something and then they die I
don't think that we need to to actually
carry it out if we don't think it will
maximize hedonic well-being mmm ignoring
the side effects like there are probably
good heed mystic reasons to fulfill
deathbed wishes so that current people
will not be afraid that their wishes
won't be kept also so as far as the bit
flippin I think a bit flipping agent
does I think its preference does have
moral significance but I weigh organisms
in proportion to the sophistication of
their minds so I care more about a
single human than a single ant for
example because a human has more
sophisticated cognitive machine or it
can do more kinds of have more kinds of
thoughts about its own mental states
when a human has a preference there's
more stuff going on within its brain to
kind of back that up so to speak so a
very simple computer program that has a
very simple preference to flip a bit it
doesn't matter very much to me because
there's not a lot of substance behind
that preferences you could think of it
as an extremely simple mind what if it's
a super intelligence that just wants to
keep flipping bits so in that case I
would give a significant way because it
has so much substance in its mind it
probably has lots of internal processes
that are reflecting on its own welfare
so to speak so yeah if it's a very
sophisticated mind I would give that
significant weight it might not override
the preferences of seven billion humans
combined I tend to give less than linear
way to larger brains so as the size of
the brain increases I don't scale the
the moral weight of the organism exactly
linearly so that would help to reduce
kind of utility monster conclusion given
Brian's meta ethics being an anti
realist and sort of viewing himself as
an emotivist I guess the the reasons or
arguments that you could provide I guess
against this view would only be they
don't refer back to any sort of
metaphysical objective anything really
so David wouldn't you say that in the
end it would just be sort of your
personal emotional choice whether or not
to find something compelling here it's
to do with the nature of first-person
facts what is it that the equations of
physics ultimately describe and if you
think subjectivity or at least take
seriously the conjecture that subject
is the the essence of the physical fire
in the equations then yeah it is just
objectively the case that first-person
agony is dis valuable but here we get
into some very controversial issues I
would just like to go back to one thing
Brian was saying about sophistication I
don't think it's plausible that let's
say a pilot whale is more cognitively
sophisticated than humans but it's very
much an open question whether a pilot
whale with a substantially larger brain
substantially larger neocortex
substantially larger pain and pleasure
centers that the intensity of experience
on the Gan Gan by a pilot whale let's
say may be greater than that of humans
therefore other things being equal I
would say that it's a profoundly
aversive States undergone by the whale
matter more than a human it's it's not
the level of sophistication or
complexity that counts do you want to
unpack a little bit your view about the
hedonic versus the Preferences and
whether or not preferences have any
weight in your view only indirectly
weight in that yeah ultimately yeah as I
said I think watch matters is the
pleasure pain axis and preferences only
matter insofar as they impact that but
thanks to natural selection we have
countless millions and billions of
preferences that are being manufactured
all the time as social primates
countless preferences conflict with each
other there is simply no way to
reconcile a lot of them whereas one can
continue to enrich and enhance
well-being so yeah sure other things
being equal satisfy people's preferences
but in so many contexts it is logically
impossible to do so from politics the
Middle East interpersonal relationships
to people's desire to be the world
famous this that or the other it is
logically impossible to satisfy a vast
number of preferences I think it'd be
interesting and useful to sort of dive
into within justification theories like
moral epistemology and ethical
motivation so I think I want to turn to
Brian now and Brian so I'm curious to
know if it's possible given your view of
anti-realism been suffering focused
ethics whether or not you can make moral
progress or what it means to make moral
progress how does one navigate the realm
of moral issues in your view given the
meta ethics that you hold and why are I
or others or why not I or others to
follow your ethics or not moral progress
I think can be thought of as many people
have a desire to improve their own moral
views using standards of improvement
that they choose so for example a common
standard would be I think that the moral
views that I will hold after learning
more I will generally now kind of defer
to those views as the better ones there
might be some exceptions especially if
you get too much into some subject area
that distorts your thinking relative to
the way it was before but basically you
can think of brain state changes as
either being approved of were not
approved of by the current state and so
a moral progress would consist of doing
updates to your brain that you approve
of sort of like installing updates to
computer that you choose to install
that's what moral promise would be
basically you designate which which
changes do I want to happen and then if
those happen according to the rules then
it's on a progress relative to what my
current state thought you can have
failures of goal preservation the
example that eliezer yudkowsky gives is
if you give Gandhi a pill that would
make him want to kill people
he should not take it because that would
change his goals in a way that his
current goal is don't approve of so that
would be moral anti-progress relative to
God his current goals so yeah that's
that's how I would think of it and
different people have different
preferences about how much you can call
preference idealization preference
idealization is the idea of imagining
what preferences you would hold if you
knew more we're smarter had more
experiences and so on and so different
people can want different amounts of
preference idealization there are some
people who say I have almost no idea
what what I currently value and I want
to defer that to an artificial
intelligence to help me figure that out
in my case it's very clear to me that
extreme suffering is what I want to
continue to value and if I changed from
that stance that would be a failure of
goal preservation relative to my current
values but there are still questions on
which I do have significant uncertainty
in the sense that I would defer to my
future self for example the question of
how to weigh different brain
complexities against each other is
something where I still have significant
uncertainty the question of how much
weight to give to what's called higher
order theory in consciousness versus
first order theories basically how much
you think that high-level thoughts are
an important component of what
consciousness is that's an issue where I
have significant moral uncertainty so
there are issues where I want to learn
more think more about it have more other
people think about it before I make up
my mind fully on on what I think about
that so then why should you hold my
moral view the real answer is because I
want you to and I'll try to come up with
arguments to make it sound more
convincing to you I find subjectivism
troubling in I support my football team
is Manchester United and I wouldn't take
a pill that induced me to support
Manchester City because that would
subvert my values in some sense but
nonetheless ultimately support for
Manchester United is arbitrary if is is
support for the reduction of of
suffering merely akin to a one support
let's say of Manchester United
I think metaphysically they're the same
it feels very different like there's a
poorer spirits you all kind of like your
whole being is behind reduction of
suffering in the way that's not true for
football teams but ultimately there's no
no matter physical difference
intentional objects ultimately are
arbitrary that natural selection has
eschewed us so define certain
intentional objects so intentional
objects this is lost we jargon for the
things we care about whether sort of
football or politics or anything but
nonetheless it's unlike these arbitrary
intentional objects it just seems to be
built into the nature of agony or
despair that they are dis valuable it's
simply not possible to instantiate such
states and find it an apron question
whether they're disabled or not I don't
know if we want to debate now but I
think it is possible I mean we already
have examples of you know one organism
who finds the suffering of another
organism to be positively valuable but
they are not mirror-touch synesthesia t
perceive what is going on and sin
insofar as one does either a sort of
mirror-touch synesthesia can do the
equivalent of a Vulcan mind-meld or
something like that one is not going to
perceive the dis fallible as valuables
an epistemological limitation but my
objection to that is it depends how you
hook up the wires between the two minds
like if you hook up one person suffering
to another person's suffering then the
second person will say it's all so bad
but if you hook up one person's
suffering neurons to another person's
pleasure neurons then the second person
will say it's good so it just depends
how you hook up the wires
it's it's not it's not all or nothing
but oh but if one is let's say a mirror
touch
to day you know in someone's you know
they stub their toe and you you have an
experience of pain it's simply not
possible to take pleasure in their
stubbing their toe I think if one does
have this notional God's eye perspective
an impartial view from lo where that one
will act accordingly and I disagree with
that because I think you can always
imagine just reversing the motivational
byers so to speak just flip the wire
that says this is bad flip it to saying
this is good in terms of the the agents
motivation right yes I was trying to
visualize what this would entail so even
in the in a synesthete example just
imagine a brain where the same stimulus
currently in normal humans the stimulus
triggers negative emotional responses
just have the the neurons hook up to the
positive emotional responses instead
but once again wouldn't this be an
epistemological limitation rather than
some deep metaphysical truth about the
world well depends how you define
epistemology but you could be like a
psychopath where you correctly predict
another organisms behavior but you don't
care so you can have a difference
between beliefs and motivations and so
the beliefs could correctly recognize
the suffering but the motivations could
have the wires flipped such that there's
motivation to cause more of the
suffering it's just that we I would say
that the psychopath has an
epistemological limitation in that the
psychopath does not adequately take into
account other perspectives in that sense
it's like a path lacks an adequate
theory of mind the psychopath is
privileged in one particular here and
now over other here and now which is not
metaphysically sustainable so it might
be a definitional dispute like whether
you consider having proper motivation to
be part of the epistemological accuracy
or not it seems you're saying if you're
not properly motivated to reduce it you
don't have proper epistemological access
to it by definition
yes I mean I one has to be extremely
careful with using this term by
definition but yes I would say that we
are all to some degree
sociopathic one is quasi sociopathic to
one's future self for example insofar as
one that se doesn't prudently save that
squanders money you know money and stuff
but we are far more psychopathic towards
other sentient beings become what's one
is failing to fully to take into account
their perspective it is this hardwired
system illogical limitation the one
thing I would very much agree with Brian
on is kind of moral uncertainty and
being prepared to urge reflection and
take into account other perspectives and
allow for the possibility one can be
wrong it's not always possible to have
the luxury of more affection uncertainty
you know if a kid is drowning hopefully
one dashes into the water to save the
kid is this the right thing to do well
what happens if the kid as this is a
real story happens to be a toddler who
grows up to be a doll fit there and
plunges the world into war one doesn't
know the long-term consequences of one's
actions but wherever possible yes one
urges reflection and caution in the
context of a discussion or debate well
isn't qualifying ones uncertainty
agnosticism carefully but in a more
deliberative context perhaps what one
should certainly do so
let's just bring it a little bit back to
the ethical epistemology behind an
ethical motivation behind your
hedonistic imperative
given your objectivism and I guess here
it also be interesting to know if you
could also explore key metaphysical
uncertainties and physical uncertainties
and and what more and how we might go
about learning more about the universe
such that your view would be further
informed you know happy to launch into a
long spiel about my views one thing I
think it really is worth stressing is
that one doesn't need to buy into any
form of view to the terrorism or
suffering focused ethics to believe that
we can and should face out the biology
of involuntary suffering it's common to
all manner of secular and religious
views that we should be other things
being equal minimizing suffering
reducing unnecessary suffering and this
is one thing that technology
biotechnology allows us to do and
support for something like you know
universal access to pre-implantation
genetic screening phasing out factory
farming and shutting slaughterhouses
going on to essentially yeah reprogram
the biosphere it doesn't involve a
commitment to some particular one
specific ethical or meta ethical view I
mean it you know for something like pain
free surgery and it anaesthesia you
don't need to sign up for it to
recognize it's a good thing and I
suppose yeah my interest is very much in
building bridges with other ethical
traditions so yeah I am happy to go into
some of my own personal views but I just
don't want to tie this idea that we can
use biotech to get rid of suffering into
anything quirky or idiosyncratic to me
and I have a fair number of
idiosyncratic views
it would be interesting if you'd explain
whether or not you think that super
intelligences or AGI will necessarily
converge on what you view to be
objective morality or if that is
ultimately down to AI researchers to be
very mindful of implementing I think
there's a real risk here when one that
one is it starts speaking as though
posthuman superintelligence is going to
end up endorsing a version of one's own
views and values which a priori is if
one thinks about is extremely unlikely
but I think too one needs to ask yeah
when one is talking about posthuman
super intelligence if posthuman super
intelligence is biological descendants I
think posthuman super intelligence will
have a recognizable descendant of the
pleasure pain axis I think it will be
ratcheted out so that say experience
below hedonic zero is impossible but in
that sense I do see a convergence by
contrast if one has a conception of post
tumor and super intelligence such that
post human super intelligence may not be
sentient may not be experiential at all
then there is no guarantee that such a
regime would be friendly to anything
recognizably human in its values
the crux here there are different ways
of doing value alignment and one such
way is descriptively through a super
intelligence being able to gain enough
information about the set of all values
that human beings have and say aligning
to to those or to some fraction of those
or to some idealized version of those
through something like coherent
extrapolated volition another one is
where we embed a moral epistemology
within the machine system and so that
the Machine becomes an ethical reason er
almost a moral philosopher in its own
right and it seems that you've given
your Objectivist ethics that with that
sort of moral epistemology it would be
able to converge on what is true
do these different paths for it make
sense to you and or it also seems that
the role of mind-melding seems to be
very crucial and core to the realization
of the correct ethics in your view with
some people their heart sinks when the
topic of machine consciousness crops up
because they know there's going to be a
long inconclusive philosophical
discussion and a shortage of any real
empirical tests but yeah I will just
state I do not think a classical digital
computer is capable of phenomenal
binding therefore it will not understand
the nature of consciousness or pleasure
and pain and I see the notion of value
and this value is bound up with the
pleasure pain axis and so in that sense
I think what we're calling machine
artificial general intelligence in one
sense it's invincibly ignorant I know a
lot of people would disagree with this
description but if you think humans or
at least some humans spend a lot of
their time thinking about talking about
exploring consciousness in all its
varieties in some cases exploring
psychedelia what are we doing there are
a vast range of cognitive domains that
are completely cognitively inaccessible
to digital computers
putting aside the issue of machine
consciousness
it seems the being able to sort of first
person access hedonic states provides a
extremely foundational and core
motivational or at least a system
illogical role in your ethics David yes
I am part of intelligence involves being
able to distinguish the important from
the trivial rich ultimately as far as I
can see boils down to the pleasure pain
access and digital zombies have no
conception of what is important or what
is trivial I would say why would that be
if a trip a true zombie in the David
Chalmers sense is functionally
isomorphic to a human and so presumably
that zombie would properly care about
suffering because all its functional
behavior is the same so do you think in
the real world digital computers can't
do the same sort of functional
computation that a human brain does none
of us have the slightest idea how one
would set about programming a computer
to do the kinds of things that humans
are doing when they talk about and
discuss consciousness when when they
take psychedelics or discuss the nature
of the self
I'm not saying workarounds are
impossible I just don't think there
spontaneously going to happen I agree
just like building intelligence itself
it requires a lot of engineering to
create those features of human-like
psychology I don't see why it would be
physically or technically impossible to
instantiate an emulation of that
architecture or an architecture that's
basically identical to it in a machine
system I don't understand why computer
architecture computer substrate is
really so different from biological
architecture or substrate such that it's
impossible for this case it's whether
once feels the force of the binding
problem or not in that you know the
example one can give you know imagine
the population of the US a skull bound
Minds
imagine them implementing any kind of
computation you like I
ultra fast electromagnetic cycling far
faster than petrochemical signaling in
the CNS is normally conceived
nonetheless short of a breakdown with
monistic physicalism there is simply no
way the population of the USA is
spontaneously going to become a subject
to experience tap to apprehend
perceptual objects essentially all you
have is a micro experiential zombie and
the question is why are 86 billion odd
membrane-bound supposedly classical
neurons any different ie why aren't we
micro experiential zombies one way to
appreciate anything the force the
adaptive role of phenomenal binding is
to look at syndromes we're finding even
partially breaks down such as a similar
tonic nausea where the subject can only
see one thing at once or motion brain
blindness or aching atop Co where one
can't apprehend motion or severe forms
of schizophrenia where there is no
longer any unitary self somehow right
now you instantiate a unitary world
simulation populated by multiple
phenomenally bound dynamical objects and
this is tremendously Fitness enhancing
and the question is how can a bunch of
membrane bound nerve cells a pack of
neurons carry off what is classically
impossible everyone can probe the CNS
with temporary coarse-grained neuro
scans and one concern individual feature
processors edge detectors motion
detectors color detectors but apparently
there are no Oh perceptual objects there
how is it that right now that your mind
brain is capable of running this ego
centric world simulation in almost
real-time it's astonishing computational
feat I argue for a version of quantum
mind but one needing by into this to
recognize that it's a profound an
unsolved problem and why aren't we like
the population of the USA
just to bring this back to the AI
alignment problem in putting aside
issues in phenomenal binding and in
consciousness for a moment putting aside
all so thick conception that super
intelligence is likely to be some sort
of biologic and Stan Shi ation if we
imagine sort of the more a I safety
mainstream approach the sort of Miri
idea of there being simply a machine
super intelligence it seems that in your
view David and I think here this
elucidates a lot of the
interdependencies and difficulties where
ones meta ethical views are intertwined
in the end with what is true about
consciousness and computation it seems
that in your view it's it close to or
almost maybe perhaps impossible to
actually do a eye alignment or value
alignment on machine super intelligence
it is possible to do value alignment but
I think the real worry is that if you
take the the Miri scenario seriously
this sort of recursively self improving
software that will somehow this runaway
intelligence it there's no knowing where
it may lead but Miri as far as I know
have very different conception of the
nature of consciousness and value I'm
not aware that they tackle the binding
problem I just don't see that subjects
of experience unitary subjects to
experience with values or a pleasure
pain access as spontaneously came to
emerge from software it seems to involve
some form of of strong emergence
right and I guess so just to sort of tie
this back and ground it a bit it seems
that the portion of your meta ethics
which is going to be informed by
empirical facts about consciousness and
minds in general is sort of the view in
there that without access to the
phenomenal pleasure pain access which
you view to have sort of like in
intrinsic goodness or wrongness to it
because it is sort of foundationally and
physically and objectively the pleasure
pain access of the universe the heat in
the spark in the equation I guess as you
say the without access to that then
ultimately one will go awry in one's
ethics if one does not have access to
phenomenal hedonic states given that
that's the core of value yeah in theory
an intelligent digital computer stroke
robot could impartially pave the cosmos
with either deloria more he donia
without actually understanding the
implications of what it was doing he'd
only am being or you to the Train iam
matter energy optimized for pure bliss
at DeLorean being matter and energy
optimize for one for better word for
pure misery or despair that the system
in question would not understand the
implications of what it was doing and
that I know a lot of people do think
that well sooner or later
classical digital computers are machines
again to kind of wake up but I don't
think it's going to happen or rather
we're not talking about hypothetical
quantum computers next century and
beyond but simply an extension of
today's programmable digital computers I
think they're zombies and will remain
zombies so fully autonomous agents which
are very free and and super intelligent
in relation to us will in your view
require a fundamental access to that
which is valuable which is phenomenal
States which is the phenomenal pleasure
pain access and without that it's
missing a sort of key epistemological
ingredient and so it will fail in value
alignment yes
yeah yeah it just simply does not
understand the nature of the world it's
rather like claiming that a system is
intelligent but doesn't understand the
second law of thermodynamics it's not a
spectrum superintelligence I guess my
open question there would be then
whether or not it would be possible to
not have access to fundamental hedonic
states but still be something of a
bodhisattva with a robust moral
epistemology that was sort of heading in
the right direction or what might be
objective the system in question would
not understand the implications of what
it was doing right it wouldn't
understand the implications but if it
got set off in that direction and it was
simply achieving the goal then I think
in some cases we might call that value
aligned
yes one can imagine sorry Brian they do
intervene when you're ready but yeah one
could imagine for example being
skeptical of the possibility of
interstellar travel for biological
humans but programming systems to go out
across the cosmos or at least within our
cosmological horizons and convert matter
and energy into pure bliss I mean one
needn't assume that this will apply to
our little bubble of civilization but
what should we do about inert matter and
energy elsewhere in the galaxy one can
either leave it as it is or if one is
that say a classical utilitarian one
could convert it into pure bliss and
yeah one can send out probes one could
restructure reprogram matter energy in
that way that would be a kind of
compromise solution in one sense keep
complexity within our little tiny bubble
of civilization but it converts the rest
of the accessible cosmos into pure bliss
and so though that technically would not
strictly speaking maximize the abundance
of positive value in a Hubble volume
nonetheless it could become
extraordinarily close to it from a
classical utilitarian perspective Brian
do you have anything out here well I
disagree on many many points I think
digital computation is capable of
functionally similar enough processing
as the brain does but even if that
weren't the case a paperclip Maximizer
with a very different brain architecture
would still have a very sophisticated
model of human emotions and its
motivations wouldn't be hooked up to
those emotions but it would understand
for all other senses of the word
understand human pleasure and pain so
yeah I see it more as a challenge of
hooking up the motivation properly so as
far as my thoughts on alignment in
general based on my meta ethics it I
tend to agree with the the default
approach like the Murie approach which
is unsurprising because miri is also
anti-realist on meta ethics so that
approach sees the task as taking human
values and somehow translating them into
the AI and so that could be in a
of different ways learning human values
implicitly from certain examples or with
some combination of maybe top-down
programming of certain ethical axioms I
mean that that gets into exactly how you
do alignment and there are lots of
approaches to that but the basic idea
that you need to specifically replicate
the complexity of human values in
machines and the complexity of the way
humans reason and it won't be there by
default in any way is shared between my
opinion and that of the mainstream AI
alignment approach so do you take a view
and similar to that of a coherent
extrapolated volition in case anybody
doesn't know coherent extrapolating
volition is eliezer yudkowsky x' idea of
giving the AI the kind of a meta you
could call the meta ethics it's kind of
a meta rule for learning values to take
humanity and think about what humanity
want to want if it was smarter new had
more kind of positive interactions with
each other and thought faster and then
try to identify points of convergence
among the values of different idealized
humans so in terms of theoretical things
to aim for
I think CEV is one reasonable target for
reasons of cooperation among other
humans I mean if I controlled the world
I would prefer to have the AI implement
my own values rather than humanity's
values because I care more about my
values some human values are fairly
abhorrent to me and others seem at least
unimportant to me but in terms of
getting everybody together to not fight
endlessly over the outcome of AI in this
kind of theoretical scenarios Eevee
would be a reasonable target to strive
for but in practice I think that's
unrealistic like a pure CV is
unrealistic because the world does not
listen to moral philosophers to any
significant degree in practice things
are determined by politics economic
power technological and military power
and forces like that those determine
most of what happens in the world I
think we might see approximations to CEV
that are much more crude like you could
say that democracy is sort of an
approximation to CEV in the sense that
different people with different values
at least in theory you know
discuss their differences and then come
up with a compromise outcome so
something like democracy
maybe power weighted democracy in which
more powerful actors have more influence
will be what what ends up happening and
so the Philosopher's dream of idealizing
values to perfection is unfortunately
not going to happen but we can push in
directions that are slightly more
reflective we can push society towards
slightly more reflection towards
slightly more cooperation and things
like that
couple of points there first what to use
an example we touched on before what
would be coherent extrapolated volition
for all the world's football supporters
essentially there's simply no way to
reconcile all their preferences one may
say that if they were fully informed
football supporters wouldn't waste their
time passionately supporting one team or
another but essentially I'm not sure
that the notion of coherent
extrapolating volition there would make
sense and of course there are much more
serious issues than football but the
second thing when it comes to the nature
of value regardless of one's
metaphysical stance on whether one's a
realist or an anti realist about value I
think it is possible by biotechnology to
create states that are empirically
subjectively far more valuable than
anything and is physiologically feasible
today I mean take Prince Myshkin in
Dostoyevsky's the the idiot like
Dostoyevsky was a temporal lobe
epileptic and he said I would give my
whole life for this one instant
essentially there are states of
consciousness that are empirically super
valuable and rather than attempting to
reconcile irreconcilable preferences I
think you could say that we should be a
you know insofar as we aspire to long
term full-spectrum super intelligence
perhaps we should be aiming to create
these super valuable states I'm not sure
whether it's really moderate morally
obligatory I've said my own focus is on
ya the overriding importance of phasing
out suffering but for someone who
else give some weight or equal weight to
positive experiences positively valuable
experiences that there is a vast range
of valuable experience that is
completely inaccessible to humans that
could be engineered for our
biotechnology
a quart difference here is going to be
that given Brian's view of anti-realism
a eye alignment or value alignment would
in the end be left to those powers which
he described in order to resolve
irreconcilable preferences that is if
human preferences don't converge
strongly enough after enough time and
information that there are no longer
irreconcilable preferences which I guess
I would suppose is probably wrong which
which is wrong that it would be wrong
that human beings preferences would
converge strongly enough that there
would no longer be irreconcilable
preferences after coherent extrapolated
volition okay I agree so I'm saying that
so in the end value alignment would be
left up to economic forces military
forces other forces to determine what
comes out of value alignment but but in
David's view it would simply be down to
if we could get the epistemology right
and we could know enough about value and
the pleasure pain access and and the
metaphysical status of phenomenal states
that that would be value alignment would
be to capitalize on that I didn't mean
to interrupt you Brian do you want to
jump in there I was gonna say the same
thing you did that I agree with David
that there would be irreconcilable
differences and in fact many different
parameters of the CEV algorithm would
probably affect the outcome one example
that you could give is that people tend
to crystallize their moral values as
they age and so you could imagine
somebody who was presented with
utilitarianism as a young person would
be more inclined toward that whereas
maybe if that person had been presented
with the ontology as a young person
person would favor deontology as he got
older and so depending on seemingly
arbitrary factors such as the order in
which you are presented with moral views
or what else is going on near near life
at the time that you confront a given
worldview or a hundred other inputs the
output could be sensitive to that and so
Zev is really a class of algorithms
depending on how you tune the parameters
you could get substantially different
outcomes so yeah it CBS he is an
improvement even if there's no obvious
unique target and as I said in practice
we won't even get pure CEV but we'll get
some kind of very rough power weighted
approximation similar to our present
world of democracy and competition among
various interest groups for
just to sort of explain on how I'm
feeling so far I mean Brian I'm very
sympathetic to your view but I'm also
very sympathetic to David's view and I
kind of hover somewhere in between
I like this point that David made where
he quoted Russell something along the
lines that one one ought to be careful
when discussing ethical metaphysics that
one is not simply trying to make one's
own views and preferences objective yeah
one is talking about well just just in
general when one speaks about the nature
of for example posthuman
superintendent's think think of the way
today that the very nature and nation of
intelligences are contested simply
sticking the word super in front of it
is just how illuminating is it when I
read you know someone's account of super
intelligence and really reading an
account of what kind of person they are
their intellect and their values I'm
sure you know when I discuss you know
the nature of full spectrum super
intelligence a listener can see what I
can't the extent to which I'm simply
articulating my own limitations I guess
for me here to get on my partialities
out of the way I kind of hope that
objectivism is true because I think that
it makes it valuable I'm in way less
messy and in the end that we could have
something actually good and beautiful
which I don't know some sort of
preference that I have that might be
objective or not or just simply wrong or
confused but the descriptive picture
that I think Brian is committed to which
gives rise to this sort of Miri and
tamasic form of anti realism is just
sort of one where in the beginning there
was like entropy and noise and many
generations of stars fusing atoms and to
heavier elements and one day one of
these disks turned into a planet and a
Sun shone some light on a planet and the
planet began to produce people and
there's an optimization process there in
the end which simply seems to be
ultimately driven by entropy and
morality seems to simply be a part of
this optimization process which just
kind of works to facilitate and mediate
the relations between angry mean
primates like ourselves we point out
there's also a lot of spandrel to
morality in my opinion especially these
days now that we're not
we optimized by biological pressures so
all this conversation that we're having
right now is a spandrel in the sense
that it's just an outgrowth of certain
abilities that we evolved but it's not
at all adaptive in any direct sense
right and so in this view it really just
seems like morality and suffering and
all of this is just a byproduct of the
screaming entropy and noise of whatever
led to this universe but at the same
time this sort of objective process and
I think this is the part the people who
are committed to sort of miri
anti-realism and sort of I guess just
relativism skepticism about ethics in
general maybe are not tapping into
enough but at the same time this
objectivity is producing a very real and
objective phenomenal sailfin story which
is caught up in suffering where
suffering is really really suffering and
it really sucks to suffer and it all
seems sort of at face value true in that
moment throughout the suffering that
this is real the suffering is real the
suffering is bad it's pretty horrible or
this bliss is something that I would
never give up or if the rest of the
universe were this bliss that would just
be the most amazing thing ever they
didn't this sort of very subjective
phenomena like just experiential thing
that the universe produces the
subjective phenomenal story and
narrative that we live it seems there's
just this huge tension between that and
I think the anti-realism the just the
the clear suffering of suffering and
just being a human being I'm not sure if
there's a tension because the
anti-realist agrees that humans
experience suffering as meaningful and
they experience it as the most important
thing imaginable and so there's not
really attention and you can explore why
humans quest for objectivity there seems
to be certain glow that attaches to
things by saying that they're
objectively moral but that's just sort
of a weird quirk of human brains I would
say that ultimately we can choose to
care about what we care about whether
it's subjective or not I often say even
if objective truth exists I don't
necessarily care what it says because I
care about what I care about and it
could turn out that objective truth
orders you to torture squirrels if it
does then I'm not going to follow the
objective truth on reflection I'm
not unsatisfied at all with anti-realism
because what more could you want than
what you want david feel free to jump in
if you'd like well there is just there's
this temptation to oscillate between two
senses of the words subjective
subjective and neither true nor false
and subjective and the sense of
first-person experience by being in
agony or your being in agony or someone
being in despair is as I said as much an
objective property of reality as the
rest mass of the electron I mean what we
can be doing is working in such ways as
to increase and in theory to maximize
the amount of subjective value in the
world regardless of whether or not one
believes that this has any transcendent
significance with the proviso here that
there is a risk that if one aims
strictly speaking to maximize subjective
value that one gets the you to the
throne iam shockwave but if one is as I
said what I personally advocate as
aiming for a civilization of
super-intelligent bliss on this not
asking people to give up their core
values and preferences unless one of
those core values and preferences is to
keep hit on except points unchanged
that's not very intellectually
satisfying but it's you know this idea
if one is working towards some kind of
and census and compromise I think now I
want to get into a bit more just about
ethical uncertainty and specifically
with regards to meta ethical uncertainty
I think they just given the kinds of
people that we are that even if we
disagree about realism versus anti
realism or ascribe different
probabilities to each view we might
pretty strongly converge on how we ought
to do value alignment given our kinds of
moral considerations that we have so I'm
just curious to explore a little bit
more about what you guys are most
uncertain about what it would take to
change your mind
what sort of new information you would
be looking for that might challenge or
make you revise your metal ethical view
and how we might want to proceed with AI
alignment given our meta ethical
uncertainty can you do those one by one
yeah for sure if I can remember
everything I just said so first to start
off what do you guys most uncertain
about within your meta ethical theories
I'm not very uncertain
madatha CLE I can't actually think of
what would convince me to change my met
ethics because as I said even if it
turned out that metaphysically moral
truth was a thing out there in some way
whatever that would mean I wouldn't care
about it except for like instrumental
reasons for example if it was a god then
you'd have to instrumentally care about
God punishing you or something but in
terms of what I actually care about it
would be not connected to moral truth so
yeah it would have to be some sort of
revision of the way I conceive of my own
values and so I'm not sure what that
would look like to be meta ethically
uncertain so there's a branch of meta
ethics which tries to tackle this issue
of meta ethical commitment or moral
commitment to meta ethical view so if
some sort of meta ethical thing is true
why ought I to follow what is meta
ethically true in your view Brian is
just simply why ought you not to follow
or why it not matter for you to follow
what is what is meta ethically true if
there ends up being objective moral
facts the squirrel example is a good
illustration if ethics turned out to be
you must torture as many squirrels as
possible and screw moral truth I don't
see what this abstract metaphysical
thing has to do with what I care about
myself so basically my ethics comes from
you know empathy seeing others in pain
wanting that to stop and unless moral
truth somehow gives insight about that
like maybe moral truths is somehow based
on that kind of empathy in a
sophisticated way then it would be sort
of like another person giving me
thoughts on morality but the
metaphysical nature of it would be
irrelevant it would only be useful in so
far as it would appeal to my own
emotions and sense of what morality
should be for me
if I might interject undercutting my
position and negative utilitarianism and
suffering focused ethics I think it
quite likely that posthuman super
intelligence advanced civilization with
a hedonic range ratcheted right up you
know to seventy to a hundred or
something like that would look back on
anyone articulating the kind of view
that I am that anyone who believes in
suffering focused ethics does and seeing
if there's some kind of depressive
psychosis while intuitively assumes that
as successes will be wiser than we are
and perhaps that well they will be in
many ways and yes in another sense I
think we should be aspiring to ignorance
that once we have done absolutely
everything in our power to minimize
mitigate abolish and prevent suffering I
think we should forget it even existed I
hope that eventually any experience
below hedonic zero will be literally
inconceivable
and so just to jump to you here David
what are your views about what you are
most medically uncertain about is this
this worry that what one is doing
however much one is pronouncing about
the nature of reality or the future of
intelligent life in the universe and so
on what one is really doing is some kind
of disguised autobiography and given
that quite a number of people sadly pain
and suffering have new larger in my life
then pleasure turning this into deep
metaphysical truth about the universe I
said this potentially undercuts my view
I mean I as I said I think that our
arguments against the symmetry view that
suffering is self intimating ly bad
where there is nothing self intimating
ly bad about being in sentient system or
a system that is merely content but
nonetheless yeah I
taeksoo see the possibility that all I'm
doing is expressing oblique ly my own
limitations of perspective given these
uncertainties and the difficulty in an
expected impact of AI alignment if we're
again committing ourselves to this me
review of an intelligence explosion with
quickly recursive self-improvement UM's
how would you both if you were the king
of AI strategy how would you go about
allocating your meta ethics and how
would you go about working on the AI
alignment problem and thinking about the
strategy given your uncertainties and
your views so I should mention that my
most probable scenario for AI is a slow
takeoff in which lots of components of
intelligence emerged piece by piece
rather than a localized intelligence
explosion as far as the intelligence
like if it were a hard takeoff localized
intelligence explosion then yeah I think
the diversity approaches that people are
considering is what I would do as well
it seems to me you have to somehow learn
values because in the same way that
we've discovered that teaching machines
by learning is more powerful than
teaching them by hard coding rules you
probably have to mostly learn values as
well
there might be hard-coding midst in so
yeah I would just pursue a variety of
approaches and the way that the current
community is doing and I support the
fact that there is also a diversity of
short term versus long term focus some
people are working on concrete problems
others are focusing on issues like
decision theory and logical uncertainty
and so on because I think some of those
foundational issues will be very
important for example decision theory
could make a huge difference to the ai's
effectiveness as well as issues of what
happens in conflict situations and so
yeah I think a diversity of approaches
is valuable I don't have specific advice
on where I would recommend tweaking
current approaches I guess I sort of
expect that the concrete problems kind
of work will mostly be done
automatically by industry because those
are the kinds of problems that you need
to make AI work at all so if anything I
might invest more in the kind of
long-term approaches that practical
applications are likely to ignore or at
least put off until later yes because of
my background assumptions are different
it's hard for me to deal with your
question but if one believes that
subjects of experience that could suffer
could simply emerge different levels of
abstraction I don't really know how to
tackle this because this strikes me as a
form of strong emergence and one of the
reasons why philosophers don't like
strong emergence is that essentially all
bets are off
yeah you just sort of imagine if life
hadn't been reducible to molecular
biology in hence ultimately to quantum
chemistry in physics so yeah I'm not
probably the best person to answer your
question I think yeah in terms of real
moral focus I would like to see
essentially the molecular signature of
unpleasant experience identified and
essentially you just making it
completely off-limits and biologically
impossible for any sentient being to
suffer but if one also believes that
there are or could be subjects of
experience that somehow emerge
in classical digital computers then yeah
I'm floundering my theory of mind and
reality would be wrong
I think touching on the paper that CAI
sutala had written on suffering risks I
think that a lot of different value
systems would also converge with you on
your review David so whether or not we
take the view of realism or anti-realism
I think that most people would agree
with you I think the issue comes about
with again preference conflicts where
some people are like I think even this
might be a widespread view in
Catholicism where like you view
suffering is really important because it
teaches you things and or it has some
sort of special metaphysical
significance with relation to God within
the anti-realism view with brian's view
I I would find it very just dealing with
varying preferences on whether or not we
should be able to suffer is something I
kind of just don't want to deal with
yeah that illustrates what I was
thinking about I prefer my values over
the collective values of humanity that's
one example I don't think it we dispute
you that sometimes suffering can teach
lessons the the question is are there
any lessons that couldn't be
functionally replaced by something else
this idea that we can just offload the
nasty side of life on to software and in
the case of pain nice reception one
knows that yes so they can robot
software systems can be programmed or
trained up to avoid noxious stimuli
without the nasty roar feels should we
be doing the same thing for organic
biological robots too when it comes to
this the question of suffering one can
have quite fierce and lively disputes
with someone who says that they want to
retain the capacity to suffer this is
very different from involuntary
suffering and I think that quite often
someone will concede that no they
wouldn't want to force another sentient
being to suffer against their will it
should be a matter of choice to tie this
all into AI align and again really the
the point of this conversation is the
again we're doing ethics on a deadline
if you survey the top 100 AI safety
researchers or add researchers in the
world you'll see that they give it
ability distribution of the likelihood
of human level artificial intelligence
with about a 50% probability at 2050
when this many suspect will have
enormous implications for Earth
originating intelligent life and our
cosmic endowment so our normative and
descriptive and applied ethical
practices that we engage with are all
embodiments and consequential to the
sorts of meta ethical views which we
hold which may not even be explicit I
think many people don't really think
about meta ethics very much I think that
many AI researchers probably don't think
about meta ethics very much but the end
towards which AI will be aimed will
largely be a consequence of some
aggregate of meta ethical views and
assumptions or the meta focal views and
assumptions of a select few
so I guess Brian and David to tie this
all together what do you guys view is
really the practicality of meta ethics
in general and in terms of technology
and and AI alignment as far as what you
said about meth --ax determining the
outcome I would say maybe the implicit
met ethics will determine the outcome
but I think as we discussed before 90
some percent of the outcome will be
determined by ordinary economic and
political forces you know most people in
politics in general don't think about
MIT ethics explicitly but they still
engage in the process and have a big
impact on the outcome I think the same
will be true in AI alignment people will
push for things they want to push for
and that'll mostly determine what
happens it's possible that metics could
inspire people to be more cooperative
depending on how its framed so you know
CEV as a kind of practical meta ethics
could potentially inspire cooperation if
it's seen as an ideal to work towards
although the extent to which it can
actually be achieved is questionable
sometimes you might have a naive view
where a moral realist assumes that a
super intelligent AI would necessarily
convert to the moral truth or at least a
super intelligent AI could identify the
moral truth and then maybe all you need
to do is program the AI to care about
the moral truth once it discovers it
those particular naive approaches I
think would produce wrong outcomes
because
there would be no moral truth to be
found and so I think it's important to
be wary of that assumption that a
superintelligence will figure it out on
its own and we don't need to do the hard
work of loading complex human values
ourselves but it seems like the current
AI alignment community largely
recognizes that they recognize that
there's a lot of hard work in loading
values and it won't just happen
automatically in terms of metrics
consider the nature of pain free surgery
surgical anesthesia when it was first
introduced in the mid 19th century it
was for about 15 years
controversial there are powerful voices
spoke against it but nonetheless very
rapidly a consensus emerged and we all
now almost all take it for granted for
major surgery anesthesia didn't require
a consensus on the nature of value and
meta ethics it's just this is the
obvious given our nature and we clearly
I would hope that eventually something
similar will happen not just a physical
pain but also psychological pain - just
as we now taken for granted that it was
the right thing to do to eradicate
smallpox no one is seriously suggesting
that we bring smallpox back and it
doesn't depend on consensus on Metta at
experience below hedonic zero which one
can trust we will be able to find its
precise molecular signature I hope that
consensus will emerge that we should
phase it out - sorry this isn't much in
the way of practical guidance today's
roboticists and AI researchers but I
suppose I'm just expressing my hope no I
think I sure that I think that we have
to do ethics on a deadline but I think
that there are certain ethical things
whose deadline is much longer or which
doesn't necessarily have a real concrete
deadline I like for it with your example
of the pain anesthesia drugs in my view
meta ethics is mostly useful for people
like us or other philosophers and
effective altruists
who can
our own advocacy we want to figure out
what we care about and then we go forth
and push for that and then maybe to some
extent it may diffuse through society in
certain ways but in the start it's just
helping us figure out what we want to
push for there's an extent to which the
evolution of human civilization has also
been an evolution of meta ethical views
which are consciously or unconsciously
in developed
Brian your view is simply that ninety
percent of what has causal efficacy over
what happens in the end are going to be
like military and economic and sort of
just like raw optimisation forces that
work on this planet and also politics
and mimetic spandrels for example like
people talk about the rise of
post-modernism as replacement of met
ethical realism with anti realism in
popular culture and I think that is a
real development one can question to
what extent it matters mmm-hmm maybe
it's correlated with things like a
decline in religiosity which matters
more but I think that what is one a good
example of how medics can actually go
popular in mainstream right and and so I
mean just to bring this back I think
that in terms of the AI alignment
problem I think I try to at least I'd
like to be a bit more optimistic about
how much causal efficacy each part of
thinking has causal efficacy over the AI
alignment problem I like to not all
right tend not to think that 90% of it
will in the end be due to rogue
impersonal forces like you were
discussing I think that everyone no
matter who you are stands to gain from
more meta ethical thinking insofar as
that whether you take realist or
anti-realists views the expression of
your values or whatever you think your
values might be whether they might be a
conventional or relative or arbitrary in
your view or whether they might relate
to some sort of objectivity they're much
likely less to be expressed and I think
a reasonable and good way without
sufficient medical thinking and
discussion one thing I would very much
hope that before for example radiating
out across the cosmos we would sort out
our problems on earth and the solar
system first regardless of whether one
is a
secular or religious or a classical or a
negative utilitarian let's not start
thinking about colorizing nearby solar
systems or anything there but yes if one
is an optimist one may be thinking if
opportunities for gone better at least
wait a few centuries because I think in
a fundamental sense we do not understand
the nature of reality and not
understanding the nature of reality
comes with not understanding the nature
of value and this value the experience
or value and this values Brian might put
it unfortunately I'm more pessimistic
than David I think the forces of
expansion will be hard to stop as they
always have been historically nuclear
weapons are something that almost
everybody wishes hadn't been developed
and yet they were developed climate
change is something that people would
like to stop but it has kind of a force
of its own due to the difficulty of
coordination so I think the same will be
true for space colonization and AI
development as well that we can make
tweaks around the edges but the large
trajectory will be determined by the
runaway economic and technological
situation that we find ourselves in
I fear Brian may be right I used to
sometimes think about the possibility of
so-called cosmic rescue missions if the
rare earth hypothesis it is false and
suffering Darwinian life exists within
their cosmological horizon I used to
imagine this idea that we would radiate
out and prevent suffering elsewhere a I
suspect wrote the rare earth hypothesis
is true but B I suspect even if
suffering life forms do exist elsewhere
within a Hubble volume it's probably
more likely humans or our successors
would go out and just create more
suffering or it's a rather dark and
pessimistic view in my more optimistic
moments I think we will phase out
suffering altogether in the next few
centuries but these are guesses really
right I mean so we're dealing with
ultimately given AI and it being the
most powerful optimization process or
the seed optimization process to radiate
out from Earth I mean we're dealing with
potential astronomical waste or
astronomical value or astronomical
we tie this again into moral uncertainty
and sort of start thinking about William
and castles work on moral uncertainty
where we kind of just do what might be
like expected value calculations with
regards to our moral uncertainty and
sort of try to be very mathematical
about it and and consider the amount of
matter and energy that we are dealing
with here given a super-intelligent
optimization process coming from Earth
I think the tying this all together and
considering it all should potentially
play an important role in our AI
strategy I definitely feel very
sympathetic to Brian's views that in the
end it might all simply come down to
these impersonal economic and political
and military stick and mimetic forces
which exist but given moral uncertainty
given that Ithaca uncertainty and given
the amount of matter and energy that is
at stake potentially is some portion of
a ah strategy should play into
circumventing those forces or trying to
get around them or decrease them and
their effects and hold on AI alignment
yeah I think it's two tweaks around the
edges as I said unless these approaches
become very mainstream but I think the
prior probability that AI alignment of
the type that you would hope for becomes
worldwide is low because the prior
probability that i- in thing becomes
worldwide mainstream is low but you can
certainly influence local communities
who share those ideals and they can try
to influence things to the extent
possible right but I mean maybe
something potentially more sinister is
that it doesn't need to become worldwide
if there is like a singleton scenario or
if the the power and control over the AI
is very small within like a tiny
organization or some small organization
which has power and autonomy to do this
kind of thing yeah I guess I I would
again say the the probability that you
will influence those people would be low
personally I would imagine it would be
either within a government or a large
corporation maybe we have
disproportionate impact on a I develop
err is relative to the average human but
especially as it becomes AI becomes more
powerful I would expect more and more
actors to try to have an influence so
our proportional influence would decline
well I'm feeling very pessimistic after
all of this huh morality is not real and
everything's probably going to [ __ ]
because economics and politics is gonna
drive it on the end huh
well it's also possible that we're
heading for a glorious future of
superhuman bliss beyond the bounds of
everyday experience and that this is
just the [ __ ] end of Darwinian life right
David we'll be having I think as you say
one day we might have thoughts as
beautiful as sunsets what a beautiful
night to end on we are I hope that one
day we have thoughts as beautiful as
sunsets and the suffering is a thing of
the past whether that be objective or
subjective within the context of an
empty cold universe of just entropy
great well yeah thank you so much Brian
and David do you guys have any more
questions or anything you'd like to say
or any plugs any last-minute things yeah
I'm interested in promoting research on
how you should tweak AI trajectories if
you are for most concerned about
suffering a lot of this work is being
done by the foundational Research
Institute which aims to avert s risks
especially as they are related to AI and
so I would encourage people interested
in futurism to think about suffering
scenarios in addition to extinction
scenarios and also people who are
interested in suffering focus ethics to
become more interested in futurism and
thinking about how they can affect the
long-term trajectories
visit my websites urging the use of
biotechnology to phase out suffering in
favor of gradients are intelligent bliss
for all sentient beings I'd also like
just to say thank you Lucas for this
podcast and all the work that you're
doing yeah thanks for having us on yeah
thank you two Bodhisattvas if I've ever
met them here finally thanks so much
guys if you enjoyed this podcast please
subscribe give it a like or share it on
your preferred social media platform
we'll be back again soon with another
episode in the AI alignment series
[Music]